hey guys welcome back to brand new video
Rebecca on apex legends and as of about
an hour ago the new energy weapon which
I called yes in yesterday's video I
[ __ ] called it the new energy weapon
the havoc has been released so we're
gonna hopefully find it somewhere as you
can see this is what it looks like we
got some of cool skins I'll show off the
golds look pretty solid they're pretty
cool I guess they're not too great but I
mean the weapon itself probably looks
way better when you're shooting it so
we'll probably hop into a game hopefully
get it maybe we'll get a win now I'm
gonna be playing with some randoms so
maybe we'll get a win on top of it I try
to get some kills off what the haba quiz
and uh yeah let's do it boys you'll see
in the match
[Music]
easy squad white you hate to see it Hey
look at that we got it nice now this
[ __ ] looks cool as [ __ ] I like it
oh so this fire is a fully auto and it's
a energy weapon okay let's check the
attachments we can use hop up a stock
and a site so there's two there's two
hop ups available for this weapon I
believe it is the turbo charger for the
devotion which I believe reduces the
auto fire delay with this weapon I think
it's because this is a charge oak weapon
very similar to the devotion and I
believe the select fire receiver that
the Prowler has can turn this into the
fully auto beam thing yeah yeah this is
a charge weapon it does take some time
to pop off a little bit
all right not bad it's got a little less
animal than I would expect from a
charged up weapon but make things work
hi my name is really shitty right there
though I was all my fault okay yeah this
thing this thing's pretty powerful holy
[ __ ] I'm not am below it's the only
problem with this weapon is that's an
energy weapon there so obviously you're
not going to get lots of ammo cos energy
and most somewhat scarce compared to the
other types of ammo that's the energy
I'm looking for nice this is a 25 round
clip 25 and then there is no extended
mag so we can't go any farther with that
there's only 25 kind of I feel like
maybe just cuz of my accuracy but I feel
it's a little bit less that's that's not
too much ammo for a weapon
that has like a like a charge of like at
least with the devotion it's got like 40
44 I think at least from what I remember
but I feel like this could have a little
bit more but I understand maybe I'm just
not using the weapon at its full
potential just yet you're gonna you can
take the shoot
dick alright then then use that then use
the cell what are you talking about it
then use the shield cell you just said
there were no shield what do you mean
I'm so confused
skull piercer for the wingman hop up no
extended mag I'll take it though always
be taking extended mags that's what I'm
liking alright selects fire receivers so
this is the so we got single mode and
auto mode interesting so I can tap it
then alright we'll have to use that in a
fight so select fire allows me to tap
and then the auto fire alright
interesting interesting next engagement
I'm gonna try to use a little bit of
both I think there's somebody near me
actually
oh my god this gun is [ __ ] nuts do
all I [ __ ] I clapped her shield and
down is just one mag holy [ __ ] it's gone
tears there's a really nice swapping hi
let's try this single fire real quick oh
[ __ ] Wow [ __ ] stupid
alright so me haha I mean it's stupid
yeah I should have probably not add
single fire on all right the single fire
is the beam but it's still a charged up
I was thinking it's like a g7 or you're
tapping it and stuff and not going back
like that are ya I [ __ ] up a little
bit that's my fault thank you alright so
now I know what the single-player does
that's more of a long-range thing I
would say or maybe like medium whereas
the I should definitely use the fully
auto one a lot more so there is the
thing that said the auto fire delay for
the turbocharger my thoughts is that
it's gonna be like the devotion we're
just charges up faster I'm not expecting
anything like - while with it
[Music]
you got bamboozled I hid them as Steef
and everything that's that's a shame and
it's not much I could do it that one
I feel like this weapon is more gonna be
used for like your medium range and
maybe somewhat of your short range
because I feel like every well to be
fair if that guy didn't have the Mastiff
in like to shot me then I probably would
have killed him I would have been really
low on health my intent wasn't to fall
down
I just wanted to mark the person I've
ended up screwing me up anyway I feel
like even if I pick the corner he
probably would have smokes me with that
gun so like I'm not too ashamed about it
maybe the turbo torture would help out
in a short-range scenario but surprise
surprisingly I didn't even find a turbo
charger that's I usually find that stuff
like every game but I guess not
that's that was very surprising he's got
pretty good he's got pretty good
leverage in this play since there isn't
many places he could be flanked besides
that one area big boy didn't walk out of
that confrontation get smoked up a
peacekeeper feels bad all right well
that was a good attempt I got 5 kills
nope nope
[ __ ] so what exactly happened to going
over there because unless I'm wrong you
marked over there and this isn't skull
town where the [ __ ] are we go oh where
in the [ __ ] is my other [ __ ] teammate
dude Oh what is my mans doing what what
what what is he what is he doing
we were we were over wait where were we
actually we were over here and this
means is out here what the [ __ ] is going
on
yeah it's about how much that's about as
much as I expected from that one mom GG
boys I have boys it's gonna be the end
of a day I hope you guys did enjoy sorry
I couldn't get the havoc as much as I
wanted I picked it up once or twice I
couldn't really do anything with it and
then I played for like another hour and
a half and I could not find anything
I guess my luck is just shitty but
honestly personal opinions just from the
weapon I think it's really solid I think
if you do get the turbocharger it'll be
a lot better than what I was showing on
screen since I didn't have it but I
think it's actually a pretty solid
weapon and it gives some love to the
energy side of weapons so hopefully a
lot more people will use that and maybe
we'll find a lot more energy ammo
because sometimes I go like matches
without finding any which is the huge
problem because of how much ammo those
weapons waste so maybe that will be
changed in the future I have no clue big
guys like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of apex legends that
being the balance changes the new
legends the new weapons that come all
I'll show a gameplay of them I'll talk
about anything that happens within an
update so if you never do want to miss
an update with apex legend stuff which
they subscribe to the channel I mean
that guy's my two most doodles will be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out and that guy said I have a
greatest today thank you for watching
the video let me know
dots on the havoc in the comments down
below and peace out
[Music]